all right according to the paperwork I'm
Dave Rubin and this is the Reuben report
welcoming you guys to another Friday
Roundtable Extravaganza and joining me
today are the co-hosts of the chicks on
the right podcast Amy Jo Clark and
Miriam Weaver Amy Jo Miriam welcome to
the Reuben report hi great to be here
great to be here I am glad to finally
have you find ladies on I have been on
your show many times we always have a
good time and I want to dive into all
sorts of stuff before we do that I have
two quick announcements for the people
uh today through Sunday if you guys join
the Reuben report.locals.com Community
annually you not only get two months
free but we're sending you all some
Reuben report merch we're clearing out
the closets as we're about to launch an
all-new store we've got shirts from some
of our events that we've on we had a
couple shirts left over from our Miami
event we have the standard Reuben report
shirt one lucky person is going to get
this very hat which I signed myself this
is like the Willy Wonka golden ticket
hat if you get this hat you also get
tickets to a live event uh sometime this
fall just sign up at
reubenreport.locals.com
and email support
reubenreport.com so that we don't miss
you today ladies we will be talking
about the elderly man pretending to be
President Joe Biden and his obsession
with transgender children we will be
talking about the Evil Lizard person out
of California Gavin Newsom and the
juxtaposition with the sanity coming out
of Florida and then of course the the
really nutty story of the week uh the
second uh indictment of former president
Donald Trump which happened right here
in Miami before we get to that let's
talk about moink box and then we'll dive
in uh you guys know that 60 of U.S pork
production comes from one company owned
by the Chinese and their house you're
given something called ractopamine which
is banned in 160 countries including
China yet you find it in your grocery
aisle right here every day there's a
better way guys and that's why I want to
tell you about moink which is Moo plus a
link Mike delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught Alaskan salmon straight to your
door you choose the meat delivered in
every box like rib eyes to chicken
breasts to pork chops to salmon fillets
and much more plus you can cancel
anytime there's nothing better than
cooking their meats on my big green egg
on a Friday evening Shark Tank host
Kevin O'Leary called moinks bacon the
best bacon he's ever tasted and they
guarantee you'll say oink oink I'm just
so happy I got mocked keep American
farming going by signing up at
moinkbox.com Reuben right now and
listeners of this show get free filet
mignon in every order for a year that's
one of the best filet mignon you'll ever
taste but for a limited time that's
m-o-i-n-k-box.com reuben moinkbox.com
reuben and now back to me ladies before
we get into it you are professional
podcasters how was my read right there
did you feel good about that one
beautiful it was so moinky
it was moo plus oink there you go all
right well today is day 16 of pride
month and if your genitals are still
attached to you you are lucky here is a
tweet from the White House themselves
these are our kids these are our
neighbors
not somebody else's kids they're all our
kids and our children are the kite
strings that hold our national Ambitions
Aloft it matters a great deal how we
treat everyone in this country
lgbtq Americans especially children
you're loved you're heard and this
Administration has your back
Joe Biden has the backs of children who
are confused about their either gender
or sexuality or something like that how
do I decide who goes first here
I think we're both kind of we're both
kind of weirded out by this right
Amy Joe go ahead
um well I you know I remember a time
when Joe Biden
um was against gay marriage I'm old
enough to remember that so I I just I
look at him now pandering to this
community first of all my kid is not
your Kid Joe Biden but I also remember
when he just was completely against gay
marriage I remember when he was with
Obama and they were against gay marriage
so I'm old enough I'm an old lady I feel
like I guess so I remember what he was
against that community in general so I
feel like all of this is just so pandery
and this Administration in general is
just so pandry to the whole Community
whether it's um the gay community or the
transgender community and just the
lgbtqia XYZ element of P community in
general and it's just it's so
disingenuous to me Miriam I keep trying
to explain to people that these letters
have nothing to do with each other and
that actually there is no movement that
is more anti-gay actually than the trans
movement there is also no movement that
is more actively anti-female in general
that the woman than the trans movement
uh but I guess the the pandering just
never ends with these people huh it
never ends and I think you know at some
point Facebook is going to have to add a
new status that says you've been marked
safe from puberty blockers because I
mean it's getting out of control the
whole idea the whole notion of the White
House anybody at the White House and
they repeat this line often about these
being our kids just immediately makes me
put my hands up and like stay away from
my kids these are not your kids these
are my kids and when you see States like
California that are enacting some of
these crazy super weird like if you
don't affirm your kids gender ideology
at age seven we're going to take your
kid away from you I mean it's getting
it's getting real at this point and so
it's not even just about pandering it's
dangerous the way that they talk about
our kids yeah you know you guys know I'm
a new father and it is very clear that I
am the father in this case we happen to
have two dads but we are the parents of
these kids the state is not the parents
of these kids the idea that someone from
the state could knock on your door and
say oh no your son who uh actually
thinks he's a girl and since you don't
affirm that we're going to take your
child but that is literally happening in
California now it passed it passed so if
you're in Cali and you watch this show
you gotta go you gotta get out now but
to that point Elon Musk responded to the
White House's tweet about this uh oh
there are kids he wrote you are the
government they are not your kids uh Amy
how do you think we how do you think we
drive this point home a little further I
mean there are a lot of people people
that do think it takes a village they're
everybody's kids nobody really should
have the ultimate Authority on this
child well I think we learned that
during the covid pandemic right that
there are a lot of liberals there are a
lot of people on that side of the aisle
there I mean gosh I saw even some dare I
say people on the right side of the old
conservatives people who I thought were
conservatives who think and believe that
the government knows what's best for
them and knows what's best for their
children and that's terrifying it's
that's not the government's job to make
any decisions like that about your
children you are the parent I am the
parent stay out of my like I'd say the
decisions for my child that's my job as
a parent to make those decisions and
we're seeing that in education we're
seeing that in so many things it's it is
kind of terrifying that that's happening
and it's you know we see it in
California you think oh it's not going
to happen in places like I live in Texas
and so I think oh it's not going to
happen here but so many of those whack
job Californians are moving to Texas you
know no
so it's terrifying well it's funny
because here in Florida where obviously
I moved and we're getting the biggest
influx everyone that I meet that comes
up to me and says oh I used to live in
New York I used to live in Connecticut I
used to live in Cali but they always
make a point of saying but I'm not going
to vote that way but I get that that's a
certain set of people that are coming up
to me specifically right but seemingly
in Florida it is working out and people
I mean you just look at the DeSantis
results and it's working out properly
Miriam what do you make of sort of the
the liberal mom the the 35 year old
liberal mom uh that is going along with
all of this stuff like is there a way to
reach them can can a woman reach them in
a way a man cannot perhaps that's a
great question I mean we you know we
talk about these filled with white guilt
Suburban moms that are such a problem
for republicans in elections and I don't
know where the I to me they seem just
extra naive and I don't know if that's
um obviously that I'm using a broad
brush here when I say that but they seem
so
um susceptible to believing all the
nonsense from for example Robin D'Angelo
about white fragility they're the first
ones to run out and buy the book and buy
in and I've never understood how how
easy it is for them to fall into that
way of thinking but you raise a great
point about how how do you how do you
bring how do you coax them back to the
right side and man I don't know I mean
we we've talked a lot in just the last
couple days about how dumb people have
become so it's a worry right because I
don't know how that improves we've
already lost a couple years now off of
kids education the what they've learned
you know and what they haven't learned
as result of covid I don't know how we
claw our way back from how dumb we've
become right you know it's funny because
on one hand it's like all right maybe
when they realize that their sons are
not getting into colleges with better
grades than say an lgbtq kid or a black
kid or whatever that they that might
wake them up but I think they'd fall on
the sword on that one for the most part
actually yeah but let's go to another
thing this week because it is pride week
and Biden's been giving a lot of
speeches about Pride he he completely
made up that there are these hundreds of
bills these anti-lgbt bills throughout
America they simply do not exist which
is why they never go into any detail
about them it then gets repeated on
mainstream media here's Joe completely
making something up
it's wrong that the violence and hate
crimes targeting the lgbtq people is
rising it's wrong that extreme officials
are pushing hateful bills targeting
transgender children terrifying families
and criminalizing doctors
these are our kids these are our
neighbors it's cruel and it's countless
not somebody else's kids they're all our
kids
where the kids that are and our children
are the kite strings that hold our
national Ambitions Aloft it matters a
great deal
all right so there he goes again with
this they're all our kids thing but this
line the hateful bills targeting kids uh
the bills are stopping children from
having their genitals mutilated and
chemical castration and God knows what
else they are doing to these kids uh Amy
the media is just never going to deal
with this stuff honestly huh right it's
not honest it's not honest it kind of
reminds me of the the racism claims
right I mean they they make it seem like
we're all racist and we're not racist
and you go out into the real world and
we live in the real world and we know
that people are not racist it's kind of
like people are not really even
transphobic we're not transphobic if you
actually talk to real people none of
this stuff is happening and the media
does such a remarkable job of painting a
picture that's not actually happening in
real America and then we're all at each
other's throats and we're you know
hating one another and it's we're also
um I I get we're not Unified like we
were supposed to be unified like Joe
Biden wanted to or he claimed he was
going to unify us but we're all you know
we're we hate each other more than ever
in this country because of the media the
media does such a they've done such a
bang-up job at making us hate one
another and this is just one of the
examples of what they do also for the
record I say this all the time but a
phobia is an irrational fear so the idea
the idea that you're transphobic if a
government agent shows up at your house
saying I'm going to take your kid
because he really thinks he's a girl or
she really thinks he's a boy I don't
think that's an irrational fear but okay
let's let's move on because uh you guys
you guys mentioned Cali and there's just
so much great so much of the craziness
that we talk about all the time emanates
first in California so Gavin Newsom uh
who I truly believe is an evil lizard
person from another planet wearing women
out oh my God uh he went on Sean Hannity
and just laid out a whole bunch of bunk
which will be debunk in just a sec but
here's his bunk
in 2021 California at 7.8 percent of GDP
GDP growth in this country one of the
fastest growing economies anywhere on
planet Earth this state continues to be
the Temple of the American economy 25.6
of All American jobs came from this
state in April and the last two fiscal
years we enjoyed
177.7 billion dollars in operating
surpluses we're on our way to be the
fourth largest economy Eat Your Heart
Out Germany in the world number one in r
d Venture Capital more scientists
researchers more Nobel laureates more
patents emanating out of this state than
any other state in America with all due
respect Florida doesn't even come close
Eat Your Heart Out Texas California
continues to be the dominant economic
engine for them I promised you before
this interview I would let you give full
answers that's a full answer
okay so almost everything he said there
was either a lie or a confusion in terms
of some of the numbers California
despite the 1.5-ish million people who
fled is still a massive state so a lot
of their numbers seem very big but it's
purely because yes for decades it was
the place every wanted to everyone want
to go now it's the place that everyone
wants to flee uh Miriam the craziness
there people always say Well when is it
going to stop or or what is the low
Point what is what is the bottom so that
they can reverse it I see no reversal on
this thing I I think they are just going
off the deep end what do you think well
absolutely and and he just it's like he
just doesn't see what's happening right
in front of his very eyes in places like
San Francisco which is just absolutely
falling apart and he doesn't recognize
or he refuses to admit all the people
that have fled California they're
hightailing out of there with good
reason and so I don't know how he can
you know it's fine he can memorize all
of his little stats and pretend that
they are are creating this this
narrative that's utterly untrue to
anyone who has actual eyes and ears on
the ground but but you know it's clearly
false and you only need to look at the
actual things that are happening the
problem is if you go back to the people
that we were just discussing which are
the young liberal women who are riddled
with guilt they will look at Gavin
Newsom and they'll be all Gaga over him
right even though he's a lizard and he's
so smooth and the way that he rattles
off the stats and the way that he
answered Sean's questions it's it's he's
very very Charming in a way that I fear
would make him a formidable candidate
which is ultimately where it's headed
right I mean he's clearly gonna run for
president at some point and there's way
too many stupid people who are going to
be like oh my God he's so dreamy and not
actually face the reality of the
situation that he is responsible for in
California yeah he talks he talks in
circles that's what he's doing he's
talking it's like I can smell him
through the screen it's like he smells
like Bad Company
it's so gross I mean he smells like a
used car salesman with way too much
cologne on he's just like he he's a
complete scheme I know we're supposed to
be talking about data and stuff like
that but that's he's like the cult of
personality to me like he is the guy
that like he's the empty suit he says a
bunch of words they mean nothing people
buy into that crap and it's like Miriam
says it's women especially are like oh
my God ah he's so great and they're
gonna they love that crap they eat it up
he's like the perfect politician he's a
nepo baby he's so gross so gross yeah
Miriam to your point I I always say that
you know people don't have to get too
lost in the stats you just have to look
where are people leaving and where are
they going to but I do want to read you
guys a couple stats that actually will
give a little more context than what he
was tossing out there this is from the
public policy Institute of California
California's violent crime rate
increased by six percent from 440 to per
100 000 residents in 2020 to 466 in 2021
while robberies fell somewhat by 1.9
percent aggravated assaults jump Point
by
8.9 percent and homicides and rape those
are the really bad ones increased by 7.7
and 7.9 percent uh respectively and
let's just do a little bit more here
this is from California matters uh the
first Statewide snapshot of California's
homelessness crisis since the pandemic
hit reveals that the number of people
without a stable place to call home
increased by at least 22 500 people over
the past three years to a hundred
seventy three thousand eight hundred
homelessness grew by 15 guys for a
little context on that we were
discussing the San Francisco
homelessness situation once on this show
and my phone lit up while we were live
streaming and it was the mayor of Miami
and he said to me Dave we have about 200
homeless people in Miami and I'm working
on it and Miami is flourishing and that
tells you everything you need to know oh
uh Amy Gavin ruined San Francisco ruined
Cali you think this is all in
preparation to ruin the United States
huh I do
and you know he's going to run for
president that's why he's been making
the rounds on every single talk show
that's why he went on Fox for crying out
loud and then he's and he's also he's
been showing up a place he's showing up
at the White House he's just sort of
like popping up in different places now
the median home price in California I
read was like around what six hundred
thousand dollars which I mean that
that's the median so I think to myself
listen normal everyday people cannot
afford that and so my and I have kids
who live in California right now and
they're planning on moving to Texas but
I I think they can't buy a house they
rent there's no way and they make great
money there's no way that they can
afford to buy a house there it's
insanity and so the normal regular
people who have good jobs can't afford
homes there it's just unsustainable to
live there and especially if you want to
have a family and who wants to raise a
family in California especially with all
the things that you said before I mean
this is a these are these are people who
want to have raised good chill children
and they're threatening to take your
children away it's like get out of there
that's the fact that the fact that I am
saving money to live in Florida is so
crazy and I have told us at this many
times he should think about an entry tax
and and I actually really believe that I
want to show you one other number here
to really debunk what what Newsome was
saying because he's comparing what
historically Cali was and why people
move there in the first place not what
it is now this is from governing.com for
all of 2022 California's economy ranked
10th worst for GDP growth among the
states advancing only 0.4 percent versus
2.1 percent National Pace top growth was
found in Idaho at 4.9 percent then
Tennessee at 4-3 Florida at four percent
Nevada at 3-7 and Texas at 3.4 percent
so that is really the proof in the
pudding stuff that in the last two years
basically as we have lived through all
of this craziness where are people
moving Idaho Tennessee Texas Florida
anywhere else literally anywhere
what a shame because California is I
mean if you look at it from just a
geographical standpoint it's a beautiful
state it really is beautiful just if you
look at the scenery if you drive through
it and you know especially not the
cities per se but you know this the
state in general it really is beautiful
and he's ruined a beautiful state and
shame on him you know how much how much
do we care how much we think we should
care because I'm starting to care an
awful lot less I really am really if
that's the route they want to go then so
be it because where where California
goes so too follows the rest of the
country in many cases and so there's a
danger to one of the largest economies
in the country leading the way you know
that's how I'm sure how Gavin would put
it on some of these cultural issues that
really sets the stage for other states
to follow suit I hope that they don't
but there's reason to be paying
attention to it for sure and so I mean
it's it's really important that people
do you they don't look at California as
an outlier because I think that there
are other Democrat Governors who think
oh look at Gavin like look what he's
doing we should be modeling ourselves
didn't he like 10 or 15 years ago have
this big plan about solving homelessness
and throw billions of dollars at it
right
and then the problem is is that they
crap they crap in these states like he
crapped all over California and then a
lot of these Liberals are like okay
that's fine we're going to go ahead and
move to other states like the Idaho's
and the Texas's and the Colorados and
the arizonas and then I'm afraid kind of
like I said earlier that they're going
to do that in these other states they
are going to bring their because I mean
I look at Austin it's happening here and
it's and it's starting to spread it's
spreading out because I live close to
Waco it's starting to spread and that
concerns me because the Liberals are
moving to places like you think that
it's just conservatives it's not just
conservatives that are moving because I
look and I see some of the Subarus
driving around and are you telling me
it's happening in Waco can't chip and
Joanna isn't that where they flip all
their houses can't they do something
about that I wish they would they
probably would vote for Gavin though
right I mean I don't know I don't know
where they stand politically now I think
they're they're probably pretty
conservative but I mean it is starting
to Trickle and it's you know it's
starting to sort of spread out a little
bit and that does concern me because as
these people get sick of the high taxes
but yet they they go and they move and
then they bring their crappy politics
with them and that's not okay and that
is a concern so it's kind of like
crapping where you eat right that whole
notion right I mean some of that I think
is the people that tend to move towards
big cities Austin seems like it's the
place where all the people who wanted to
stay a little weird went so it went blue
we don't really again we don't really
have that in Florida from what I can
tell you I want to read one more thing
that's happening in Cali right now and
as chicks I know you guys like to shop
right that's what they say so uh
Westfield here we go Westfield Mall stop
paying its
558 million dollar mortgage and is
surrendering its namesake San Francisco
Mall the biggest in the city to lenders
in the wake of Nordstrom's planned
closure and plunging foot traffic down
42 percent from 2019 and sales are down
by a third I mean
did you see the video that was going
around even
um earlier this week because all these
stores are closing down in San Francisco
and they're hightailing it out of there
so there was just another video I just
saw it today as a matter of fact of a
bunch more looters taking advantage of
the few stores that remain so they could
empty them out too and and then we got
Gavin on Sean Hannity bragging about the
state
where's Pelosi gonna shop where's she
gonna go oh don't worry she has a
private Shopper she's not she's not
slumming it at the Westfield Mall in San
Francisco but actually one more thing on
the on the emigration that is the exit
of Cali uh this is from ABC 10. census
data shows that just counting domestic
migration in and out of the state
California overall lost 871 000 people
from April 2020 to July 2022 after
accounting for in international
migration the birth and death rate
California lost about 500 000 over two
years now we're about a year off since
that and we know that people have still
consistently been leaving California so
and I want to see this I want to see
DeSantis and him to actually do that
debate that he was like all four you
know when when handy said I really want
to see you guys debate I would love to
see him answer to that sir you gave me a
hell of a segue you gave me a hell of a
segue because DeSantis uh he's been
Newsome's going after him relentlessly
he finally responded this is just
yesterday take a look
you know it's interesting
um he's got huge problems in his State I
mean like
huge problems in his State we all know
that I mean you see it in San Francisco
you see it in LA you see it in the
people fleeing California from its
Inception gained population every single
year until he became Governor I mean
California was probably the height of
opportunity for middle-class Americans
for many many decades in this country no
one would leave there you know you would
go people were drawn to there and yet
he's the first governor that's overseen
a massive Exodus out of California and
you know you can kind of understand if
somebody comes from Minnesota and moves
to Naples better winners all this stuff
but if you're leaving like Southern
California to move to like Jacksonville
which is a great place you're not doing
it because of the weather because they
got probably of the best weather in the
country you're doing it because the
place is so mismanaged and ill-governed
that you just can't take it anymore and
so and yet with all those problems he
has a real serious fixation on the State
of Florida I mean I think it's just
bizarre that he does that but what I
would tell what I would tell him is you
know what
stop pussy-footing around are you gonna
are you gonna throw your hat in the ring
and challenge uh Joe are you gonna get
in and do it or are you just gonna sit
on the sidelines and Chirp so why don't
you throw your hat in the ring and then
we'll go ahead and talk about what
what's happening so
Miriam one of the things I say on the
show all the time is when is when you're
telling the truth it you can your body
language everything about the way you
speak you don't have to scream you don't
have to genuflect and throw papers
around and everything else and I think
something good is happening with
DeSantis right now where he's coming
into it and everything he said there was
true which is why his demeanor was so
calm versus the Gavin thing it's very
you know like I gotta tell you this
thing
um I guess I guess he's kind of goating
him into running
well we'll see if Gavin actually I mean
because Gavin I think would would prefer
to just get DeSantis in some sort of on
some sort of stage together before he'll
ever admit what he's actually doing
politically and you know desantis's
answer was absolute perfection there
um I love that he's just kind of blowing
him off and saying you know put up or
shut up everybody knows what you're
doing so just admit it and stop
obsessing with me I'm Just Not That Into
You I loved it
Amy last word it on Gavin and the
governor and then we'll move on to the
next topic yeah he's slimy he's gross
I'd love to see this too in a debate
that would just I mean I would grab my
popcorn and love every bit of DeSantis
wiping the floor with him I'm telling
you I said it on the show I don't know
how the Democrats are going to do it but
if DeSantis is the nominee it's going to
be Newsome they will not put Biden on
that stage with him oh my God and they
will gladly get rid of the first black
female VP to put him up there and that's
I don't know what trickery they have to
do to do it but I just if it's Trump I
think it will be Biden as long as he's
alive because it's you know the
juxtaposition isn't so far off but I
just don't think Biden and him on the
same stage that anyone would be it
wouldn't be obvious to everyone let's
put it that way but as long as we're
talking about Trump uh obviously the big
thing was the second in by indictment
the first one was a couple months ago in
New York this one was at a federal
courthouse here in Miami as I said
repeatedly this week it had nothing to
do with the state of Florida there are
federal courthouses in every state in
the Union uh here is Trump's attorney
after the indictment her name's Alina
hababa talking about the Biden
Department of Justice
Joe Biden himself
retained possession of classified
documents that have not been prosecuted
and none of them came into possession of
those documents while they were
president
none of them were president
who as the head and sole member of the
executive branch
has the power to summarily declassify
documents
the decision to pursue charges against
President Trump while turning a blind
eye to others
is emblematic of the corruption that we
have here
we are at a turning point in our
nation's history
the targeting prosecution
of a leading political opponent
is the type of thing you see in
dictatorships like Cuba and Venezuela
it is commonplace there for rival
candidates to be prosecuted persecuted
and put into jail
what is being done to the president
Trump
should terrify all citizens of this
country
these are not the ideals that our
democracy is founded upon
this is not our America
all right so to be clear uh she is
telling the truth there in that Biden
was found with classified documents he
was a VP at the time and VPS do not have
the right to declassify Mike Pence same
exact thing we don't even have to get
into all the things that Hillary did
with bleach bit and all the rest of it
destroying hard drives
Etc
um Amy just on that front is is that the
thing that people are most focused on
this sort of selective enforcement of
the law because I we can get into some
of the stuff in the indictment and it
does sound like Trump did some fairly
stupid things at least uh but that's
very secondary to the to the selective
portion of this yeah I mean I think
there's two different two different
things here right I mean I think he
actually did some stuff that was
probably wrong and then there's the the
two tiers of Justice part of this right
where there's you know Republicans or he
actually faces severe consequences
because it's a Witch Hunt for him
because they've been wanting I mean
there are people look at Keith olberman
wants him to die for crying out loud I
mean it's like this is if they've been
on a Witch Hunt for him since day one
they absolutely hate this guy and
they're doing a lot of things out of
just severe hatred for Trump I think we
all know that and then there's the part
where he did some stuff that was wrong
so when he gets into that courtroom
they're going to be you know putting him
on trial trial for the things that he
did not hey what did what did Joe Biden
face or not face what did Hillary
Clinton face or not face I mean it's
going to be the the things that that
Donald Trump did so he can't really use
in his defense well what Joe Biden
didn't face it and Hillary Clinton
didn't face it so he's going to have to
actually face the music for the things
that he did now do I think it's
completely unfair yeah and I think that
everybody in this country is at least
conservatives
um people on our the right side of the
aisle are looking at this and saying
this is a Witch Hunt yeah and I hope
that at the end of the day if he is
um convicted of you know criminal stuff
wrongdoing that whoever is President and
if that president is a republican
um that they pardon him I hope they do
that I hope that we all agree or at
least they agree they come together and
somebody will pardon him rally yeah I
agree I suspect that any Republican
would because it would help with some of
the healing and if it is another
Republican most likely DeSantis like
you're going to need some Maga DeSantis
healing so I think that hopefully they
would uh but uh Miriam I'm not sure how
much you paid attention to the to the
specifics in the indictment but in this
one you know the New York one isn't
isn't that dense this one is pretty
dense phone calls that were recorded uh
one of the things that seems like the
most damning is that apparently he
showed a classified map of somewhere in
the world we don't know where from the
indictment because it's classified
obviously but showed a map to one of the
members of his pack committee and
literally said to the guy this is
classified don't tell anyone about this
like he kind of did this to himself too
and again that's not diminishing
anything that Amy just said there I'm
completely on board all of that well
right and and that's that's I think um
we're seeing that problem that sort of
cognitive dissonance problem happen in
much of our audience right now because
they so focus on the unfairness of this
which is clearly unfair right that they
refuse to acknowledge that maybe just
maybe he actually up and so I
think it's okay to to do both of those
things at the same time and I don't know
why people are having such a hard time
doing that but you know and we talked
about this off air the fact that we have
audiences some of which are so devoted
and so not able to withstand even
hearing just the slightest bit of
criticism or even just news reporting
that doesn't present Trump in a good way
that they just completely shut down and
I think what's gonna happen here if
everybody does believe in having a fair
justice system the justice system has to
work and if it is proven beyond a shadow
of a doubt that he did illegal things
and he is convicted that that's one
thing the the justice system will have
done its job the next job as Amy Joe
pointed out is that the Republican needs
to Pardon him because it's been so
unfair so I think all of those things
can happen all at the same time right it
seems to me that the the out of this
thing is that DeSantis becomes president
pardons him like they acknowledge yes he
did illegal things but since we're going
to have a non-partisan you know scrutiny
of the law we're just we're going to
Pardon him let's put that behind us
because otherwise everyone that ever
runs for president in in perpetuity will
realize that they will be persecuted and
prosecuted for something one day and
that that genuinely is Banana Republic
stuff uh here's a little video of trump
at the Versailles it's a famous
restaurant here in Miami at the
Versailles Restaurant right after the
indictment
[Applause]
all right so the people there obviously
support above him that's no surprise uh
I did see this from the messenger after
which I just thought was kind of funny
and maybe indicative of sort of what
we're talking about here Trump promises
food for everyone at restaurant uh
doesn't order anything after his
indictment Tuesday Trump went to the
Miami restaurant Versailles where he
despite what he told a crowd of fans he
left in 10 minutes without ordering a
thing and basically he said that he was
going to pay for everybody it sounds
like it didn't pay for anybody I know
this is sort of petty and then he's like
whatever I'm willing to Grant him a
leash here but Amy like it's just like
it never stops
what they're saying so he's like he goes
in he's like listen drinks are on me
yeah
he said something like food for
everybody and then just walked out it's
like
we should all try that at a restaurant
I'm gonna totally do that at the next
bar I go to yeah it's like do the drinks
for everybody so this is what they're
reporting on this is what they report on
yeah okay I just I hate her I hate our
media I hate them
but I'm still gonna try this I'm still
doing this at the next bar I go to I'm
gonna be like I've always wanted to say
drinks on me and then then I'm gonna
slink out the back door I'm gonna be
like well you don't even have to say
drinks on me because that's an actual
lie you could just say food for
everybody and then walk out and then
it's like
you're not really you're not really
lying you're saying food for everybody
you're not saying who's paying so I mean
you didn't really lie yeah he said this
restaurant offers food to everybody
it doesn't discriminate against anyone
right ladies it was a pleasure finally
having you on we will do this again soon
thank you very much thank you and have a
great weekend and for everybody else
there's no post game show today because
I'm actually on the road at the moment I
will be with Governor DeSantis tomorrow
outside of Reno at The Basque fry if
you're somewhere outside of Reno
tomorrow Saturday morning I will be
there actually we'll put the link down
below so you can maybe grab tickets to
that and I will give everyone that would
request it the one second hug not the
two second hug the one second hug uh
thanks everybody have a great weekend
well any attempt to restrict drinking
and driving here is viewed by some as
downright undemocratic it's kind of
getting common this one fellow King put
in A Hard Day's Work put in 11 12 hours
a day and then get in your truck and
lace running one or two beers they're
making it laws where you can't drink
when you want to you can't you have to
wear a seat belt when you're driving and
Chris I'm going to become this country